Kobe on end with his pace and his
Cadence this time it's going to be pain
from deep and you can tell I mean the
sign the shoes that Kobe gave to him the
impact that he's had on Notch's Booker
but all of these programs trying to be
legendary with a potential three-point
play I see what you did with the B
legendary that was nice
I'll be here all week
Devin Booker has be legendary written on
his sneakers
because that was The Credo repeated to
him by Kobe when they spent time
together
[Applause]
every time he takes to the court he's
got black mamba on his mind and that be
legendary inscribed on his shoes
and look at the mistake the carelessness
by Gabriel he just drops the basketball
inbounds
and he can't touch it
great job by shamet coming up with the
loose ball and Booker does the rest
attacks the body of the shot blocker wow
gets the finish and the contact
constantly missed you by Gabriel
Mark in a blink the lead is down to four